عندما صفر حكم مباراه اليابان واسبانيا
قبل ايام معلنا الهدف ثانيه للمنتخب
الياباني اقصى المانيا من كاس العالم ومنح
التاهل لمحاربي الساموراي اعتراض الكثيرون
بحجه من الملعب الا ان التكنولوجيا كان
لها راي اخر حيث اقرت تقنيه البر ان الكره
لم تتجاوز خط الملعب بشكل كامل وبقي
ظلالها فيه اكتسب الهدف وتتاهل اليابان
على حسابي المانيا اليوم اصبحت
التكنولوجيا جزء هامه في كره القدم خصوصا
في المباريات الجاريه في ملاعب كاس العالم
في قطر غدا التقنيات جديده غير مساعد له
حكام اللعبه بكامل تفاصلها
[موسيقى]
جول
هناك العديد من التقنيات الجديده
والتكنولوجيات الجديده التي وضعتها الفيفا
في استخدام
كل مباريات مونديال قطر 2022 مونديال قطر
الذي رفع مستوى اللعبه الى مستوى اخر
تماما من حيث التقنيه والتكنولوجيا هناك
العديد من التكنولوجيات التي
تحسم العديد من الحالات الجدليه هنا في
مباريات الجاريه في هذا المونديال التقنيه
همم الشبه الالي تكنولوجيا الشبه الاليه
التي تعتمد على 12 كاميرا كامله مركبه تحت
اسقف الملاعب تتتبع 29 نقطه كامله من
اجساد اللاعبين هذا ما يضع هامشا تقريبا
للخطا في حركه اللاعبين وحركه الكره همم
اماكن تواجد اللاعبين واماكن كما تواجد
الكره اماكن تواجد اللاعبين همم
اا في التوقيت المناسب والدقيق لخروج
الكره من ارجل اللاعب الممرر نحو اللاعب
بالمستقبل همم تكنولوجيه اتاحت همم او قضت
كثيرا على هامش الخطا بالنسبه للحكام
تساعد الكثير تساعد كثيرا حكام هذه الدوره
على القضاء على الاخطاء التحكيميه التي
تثير الكثير منها الحالات الجدليه في عالم
كره القدم هناك ايضا تقنيه المستشعر همم
الموجود داخل كره اديداس التي تلعب بها
مباريات المونديال الحالي هذه التقنيه
التي تعتمد على همم تقنيه القصور الذاتي
هكذا همم هذه التقنيه التي ساعدت في وضع
حد لحاله الجده التي اثرت في مباراه
المنتخب البرتغالي امام المنتخب
الاوروجواياني وانصفت
المنتخب البرتغالي على حساب زميله
كريستيانو رونالدو
الهدف المسجل وادعى ان الكره لمست راسه
[موسيقى]